voilà j'arrive tout à l'heure de la côte
sud du pays encore en fait comme on dit
ce matin de mon cul tu vas tu vois bien
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on se retrouve devant le
cinéma les fauves est juste là pour les
voir le nouveau produit trop scolaires
crous colle on essaie c'est une marque
française qui propose des produits pour
les baroudeurs les sportifs ce qu'ils
vont montrer qu'ils n'ont peur de rien
et on va aller voir ce qu'ils vont
représenter
[Musique]
coupe de prescott commence ce matin avec
un petit déjeuner il ya pas mal de monde
on va déjà
qui est arrivé à venir voir un peu là
contre alors ici le lieu est hyper
content je pas si vous connaissez ce
cinéma
cinéma les fauvettes à paris allez à
tout le monde qui est en bas qui se
prépare pour assister à l'événement
avoir un petit peu ce qu'ils nous
préparent d'autant plus qu'aujourd'hui
il est l'invité exceptionnel
exceptionnelle qui vient ambassadeurs de
crosse cole c'est mike horn et
l'explorateur pour aller voir tout ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
crois que c'est la première fois que je
filme dans un cinéma avec ma caméra là
sans avoir absolument aucun problème ça
c'est cool l'image qui nous met en
appétit non regarder un petit peu dans
l'être au viseur et certains le croient
que le site déjà dix ans que pour cette
volonté c'est de faire vivre l'aventuré
d'or
[Musique]
il a une pêche depuis ce matin voilà
j'arrivais tout à l'heure de la casud
écrit encore on fait comme on dit ce
matin de mon cul au travail tu vois bien
l'année passée je pars accident
traversée du pont sud
quand on pense qu'il ya combien
maintenant on est 6 milliards de blair
ou sur la planète depuis quand tu
arrives en cours de faire quelque chose
qui a jamais été fait en temps vers tes
couilles et d'innovation rapidement si
tu as les couilles chaude aux commandes
du design et aujourd'hui je me dis quand
on peut tout faire avec certains de ses
nouveaux ex 4 épis pourquoi c'est un peu
difficile pour moi parce que moi je dois
faire beaucoup plus de travail pour les
plus une excuse c'est vrai que ça fait
maintenant tirer ça fait 30 ans que je
fais mes petites petit voyage partout au
monde
il y a trente ans que j'ai commencé
quand j'ai descendu l'amazone à la nage
20 km et puis tu pars ton côté tu sors
dans la rivière en espérant que tu vas
arriver de l'autre côté des photos j'ai
pris deux cent douze photos en six mois
aujourd'hui je prends aux 400 photos par
heure presque ça veut dire on peut mieux
documenter notre les aventures et puis
de partager ça assez c'est super parce
que aujourd'hui de partager c'est aussi
une manière d'inspirer dijon
[Musique]
oui
ah ah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oui
[Musique]
aujourd'hui on vous parle du un trekkeur
x4 le nouveau smartphone du cros cole
qui est là forcément grand modèle vous
le voyez bien penses quoi eh bien ma foi
plutôt pas inutile pour les sports
extrêmes pas mal d'avoir mines
fonctionnent comme à l'intérieur et
surtout parlé du logiciel émissions
évitées partager directement au
téléphone canton de pc comme ce soit
très rapide exactement sur un peu ce
matin
tu veux qu'on parle de foot à cette fin
il ya d'abord la présentation du nouveau
tracker x4 de crosse cole smartphone
fait pour l'outdoor de toute façon cros
cole c'est une marque française qui
fabrique des smartphones qui sont
uniquement destinés pas uniquement
vraiment destiné aux aventuriers aux
aventuriers qui partent en outdoor dans
des conditions extrêmes équivalent aux
smartphones qui est extrêmement
résistant avec une grande batterie et
qui leur permet de résister à des
températures jusqu'à -20 degrés à plus
de 50 degrés 50 55 degrés après bons
talents de vue mais corps entier nouvel
ambassadeur de la marque et 10 qui s'est
arrêté à moins 70 degrés forcément
c'était un peu compliqué mais au delà ça
marche plutôt pas mal alors la france
que nous a présenté un nouveau
smartphone c'est le trekkeur x 4 qui est
plutôt intéressant et surtout qui a la
très grande particularité est d'intégrer
d'une aktion calmes
à l'intérieur son smartphone parce que
l'idée
de crosse colle sur ce smartphone c'est
à dire les axiomes qu'à celle des
caméras d'action comme lego pro beaucoup
de personnes les utilisent mais au final
une fois qu'on a pris 5 go pro qu'on l'a
essayer de la sortir une fois qu'on a
filmé un truc après il faut penser à les
mettre dans son ordinateur à l'éditer si
on a bien appuyé sur le bouton parce que
c'est pas forcément avec une interface
qui est extrêmement simple la provoc
ross cowley ci lui répond en disant on
prend une ex young calmes on la met
directement dans notre smartphone et là
vous avez qu'à appuyer vous pouvez
éditer directement sans l'exporter dans
un ordinateur et ensuite vous de
partager directement sans les réseaux
sociaux avec vos amis facebook youtube
ce que vous voulez ou alors carrément
faire des live j'ai notamment sur
facebook
donc ça c'est plutôt cool parce qu'elles
pensent vraiment une problématique c'est
à dire des personnes qui partent faire
de l'outdoor ce soit d'un rando du ski
dans la mer et qui va vraiment une
action de gamme qui veulent en tournant
un smartphone une action de gamme et là
pour le coup c'est plutôt pas mal
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
parce que le constructeur cros cole
c'est que 40 % des utilisateurs de leurs
smartphones ont une action calmes ou
utilisent nations can qui sont dit
pourquoi pas l'intégrer directement d'un
autre smartphone d'autant plus que la
plupart de leurs concurrents se basent
vraiment sur la photo et un peu moins
sur la vidéo c'est le cas des grandes
marques vous prenez toujours des photos
excellente en faible luminosité des
photos vraiment amélioré la plus grosse
qu'elle a choisi d'axer sur la vidéo
vous pouvez l'immerger pendant 60
minutes à deux mètres de profondeur soit
parfait pour aller faire du canyoning
elle est en bord de mer parce que vous
voulez côté autonomie on a une batterie
de 4400 millions paire eur permettra est
plutôt tranquille lorsqu'on partait en
rando en solo pour l'arc des
accompagnateurs - vous êtes tranquille
vous avez une recharge rapide c'est la
quid charge 3 et transco nous annonce
aussi une optimisation logiciel au
niveau de la consommation de l'appareil
donc une meilleure autonomie ça bien
évidemment avoir leur phase de test mais
ce qui est vraiment intéressant et
daoukro ce que la plaisanterie focus
c'est sur la partie appareil photo ils
ont sorti la panam of technology
c'est-à-dire un appareil photo avec un
grand angle jusqu'à 170 degrés c'est à
dire en gros ce que voit le cumin ce que
vous avez sur les actions de gamme sauf
que sur les actions de gamme
vous avez un côté un peu fish eye qui va
venir arrondir là il ya une correction
logicielle pourrait choisir l'angle vous
voulez 88° 110° 140 degrés et même 170
degrés et derrière c'est le logiciel qui
va faire le job pour vous ayez une image
correcte comme vous le verrez avec vos
propres yeux
à noter que c'est une techno qui était
développé un partenariat qu'une
entreprise française qui s'appelle
immervision vous avez donc une appli
dédié natifs qui s'appelle x kahn qui
vous permet de filmer d'éditer et
partager tout en un seul et même endroit
nous pouvons faire du slow motion de
l'hyper las mais aussi une techno qui
s'appelle lippert stablex parce que
forcément vous avez de la stabilisation
mais l'idée c'est lorsque vous filmez
vos smartphones
même si vous avez une stabilisation
optique et logiciels numériques
c'est pas forcément toujours extrêmement
bons et à quel que soit le mouvement du
smartphone avec le gyroscope il va
reconnaître le mouvement et devenir
vraiment corriger calibré pour vous avez
vraiment une image qui ne bouge pas en
gros lorsque vous filmez vous aurez
vraiment quelque chose d'hyper clean
comme si vous regardiez avec vos propres
yeux sans le papier ça a l'air aussi
super intéressant à voir également leur
phase de test pouvait bien évidemment on
filmer en full hd mais également en 4k à
60 fps et vous avez aussi une fonction
des chicanes dans les deux cas ne sais
pas si vous connaissez c'est les petits
boîtiers qu'on met sur les voitures qui
filment en permanence qui filme en
boucle et lorsque vous avez un accident
pourrait dire à regarder j'ai filmé
tudor madaschi cam donc ça on retrouve
beaucoup en russie entre autres
un petit peu moins en france c'est sympa
que ce smartphone c'est qui va
enregistrer en permanence en boucle et
vous allez pouvoir en gros ont
enregistré dans le passé ce que ça va
pas le stocker ça va écraser toutes les
60 secondes ce qui était enregistrée
avant par contre si vous avez capté un
truc qui est vraiment bien vous n'êtes
pas forcément pensé à déclencher la vous
avez qu'appuyer et vous enregistrer sur
le passé ça peut être assez rigolo ça
effectivement avoir également leur phase
de test si on en appareil photo avec un
capteur de 12 mégapixels un autofocus
mixte pdf et
r nous permettra d'avoir un autofocus
qui sera excellent en faible luminosité
mais également lorsque les conditions de
luminosité sont vraiment optimale un
double flash dual tonnes vraiment
permettre d'optimiser les banques
notamment la couleur des poufs d'avoir
jeu trop clair trop blanches sont
franchement après horrible à regarder et
vous avez toujours les capteurs
environnementaux
l'altimètre le baromètre capteurs
température l'hygrométrie et en plus de
ça vous avez un capteur duvet sur la
face avant qui vous permettra lorsque
vous allez vous exposez à la plage vous
dire attention attention aux uv france à
mettre votre crème solaire en gros ça
vous évitera cramer ça c'est aussi
plutôt pas mal autre point plutôt sympa
sur le flanc droit là vous avez le
bouton home ont pointé le smartphone
vous avez également le capteur
d'empreintes digitales qui est
directement intégrée en gros lorsque
vous appuyez salle ils auront
directement
bon c'est pas une révolution mais c'est
bien qu'ils soient positionnés là et
bien évidemment il est complètement
compatible avec tous les accessoires x
ilic de la gamme cros cole c'est à dire
pour l'accrocher sur un vélo vous avez
également le xs on l'a posée sur la
poitrine lorsque vous couriez
vous voulez faire n'importe quoi comme
activité c'est bien ça va filmer
directement en gros comme ce que vous
verriez vous avez une perche cette fille
pauline sur piloter en bluetooth avec un
trépied vous posant sa voix est pas mal
d'accessoires chat smartphone le train
disponible le 25 octobre
très prochainement au tarif de 699
bokros cole va être en mesure parler
parce que les produits sont vraiment
intéressants on va les tester en
conditions on va peut juste les prendre
l'été c'est au studio on va aller
s'immerger on va aller en montagne on va
bouger de tous les côtés pour vraiment
se rendre compte de ce qu'on peut faire
avec et puis voir un petit peu si ça
nous apporte vraiment avec des
philippines notamment au niveau des
taxes locales
je suis très curieuse tout ça vraiment
intéressant parce que l'idée de pouvoir
intégrer une action gamme pour filmer
notamment pour moi ça peut être vraiment
très intéressant donc ça avoir phase de
test donc présentation plutôt cool et
puis surtout pouvoir rencontrer le
nouvel ambassadeur my porn qui va les
tester dans de conditions extrêmes quand
il fait chaud quand il fait froid
donc ça ça va être plutôt cool donc je
vous invite à faire une chose se voulant
savoir plus sur ce tracker x4 de crosse
cole c'est bien évidemment de faire
comme d'habitude à vous abonner et à
rester connectés d'ici là soyez ça je
vous embrasse
pour le soir
[Musique]